federal investigators urgently want to
know why a Chinese woman entered
president Trump's mar-a-lago resort
carrying a device with computer malware
you jingzhong is charged with making
false statements to a federal officer
and entering a restricted building over
the weekend she allegedly lied to
security to gain access the president
was in Florida at the time but not at
mar-a-lago a Secret Service statement
says it does not determine who was
invited or welcomed at mar-a-lago it is
a responsibility they say of the host
entity in Washington the House
Intelligence Committee Chairman says he
has questions about security at the
resort a lot of people do Paula Reid is
at the White House with more on this
story Paula good morning indeed Gail so
many questions
prosecutors say when John arrived at
mar-a-lago she told The Secret Service
she was headed to the pool and the club
believes she was related to one of its
members and let her in but she didn't
even have a swimsuit instead she had two
Chinese passports and a thumb drive
loaded with malware Thank You President
Trump has visited the winter White House
23 times since taking office this past
weekend he was already hitting the links
at a nearby Trump golf course by the
time John snuck into the club
prosecutors alleged Jang first
approached a mar-a-lago security
checkpoint on Saturday shortly after
noon even though security could not find
her on access lists the club believes
she was a relative of a member and
allowed her access onto the property
when John arrived in the main reception
area a staffer asked several times why
she was at mar-a-lago John finally
responded she was there for a United
Nations chinese-american Association
event the staffer knew there was no such
event and alerted the Secret Service but
John passed at least five Secret Service
agents and at least half a dozen signs
before she was apprehended this instance
was sort of a perfect storm where she
lied her way past multiple checkpoints
Fran Townsend is a CBS News senior
national security analyst they're gonna
be looking at when does she enter the
United States who did she associate with
here in the u.s. agents found four
cellphones
one laptop an external hard drive and a
thumb drive containing malware in her
possession
this incident hi
to the challenge of security at a
private club there are members there are
guests of members and there are large
events and so it just represents a
vulnerability that the Secret Service is
charged with mitigating Dom allegedly
told agents that her Chinese friend
Charles told her to travel from China to
Florida to speak with a member of the
president's family about foreign
relations the Secret Service has not
been able to corroborate that story they
say the investigation is ongoing here at
the White House this morning we have
observed many additional Secret Service
agents on duty
Norah it's fascinating that comes in the
context of course what is a national
security apparatus including with my
previous interview with the FBI director
who is warning that the Chinese are
systematically stealing secrets from
America business secrets corporate
secrets it is a huge concern for those
so I think this story continues to grow
as Paula has pointed out love a feeling
they'll get some information from her
doesn't all one always go to the pool
without your bathing suit well that's a
bit of a clue yeah